ask anyone that has been through it and
they'll all tell you the same the moving
home is maybe one of the most stressful
things that a normal person can ever
experience it's a logistical nightmare
right from the start the moment you talk
to a realtor about being interested in
selling your current house and buying
another everything goes downhill from
there after that moment an avalanche of
things comes hurtling towards you
finding a place you like making an offer
letting people look around your house
waiting for them to make a counter offer
exchanging contracts and that's before
you even have thought about packing and
as Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realtor the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possessions and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian era feel to it all beautifully
carved and varnished Woodwork and creaky
old floorboards but in more of an
elegant refined sort of way rather than
a creepier one that's not to say Milo's
new place wasn't without its more
unsettling elements aside from being big
spacious and easy to imagine as being
haunted the creepiest thing about the
house aside from its frighteningly low
price was the story of what happened to
the previous owners obviously you know
that legally we have to disclose whether
or not anyone died on this property the
realtor had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realtor instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
clients nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sentence like that Milo
asked we just have to give full
disclosure but I assure you the previous
residents didn't die on the grounds of
this house she gave that fake smile
again it was pretty ineffectual at
reassuring him so what happened to the
last owner well it's a bit of a mystery
to be honest a local Legend if you like
but hey that gives the place more flavor
hearing some spooky history right think
of what a conversation starter that will
be the realtor ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh but reigned it
back in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Shaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judge judgment on the
fact he was planning on moving in alone
but they used to spend a lot of time
tending the garden out front so their
neighbors would see them pretty
frequently which meant they were all
okay and no one had any bad mishaps in
the house you know how old folks can be
such a worry when they get to that age
yeah totally Milo interjected to where
the realtor was stalling he repeated so
what actually happened to them well
that's the thing she Shrugged Nobody
Knows the full story one day the
neighbors across the street noticed they
hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw for quite a
while so naturally they came on over
here to see if they were in and the last
thing they wanted was to assume
everything was hunky-dory here I mean
hey better save than sorry right but
once they got inside they couldn't find
either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were just
gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
realtor continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his fur had reminded Milo
of the glazed sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the Shah still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes are a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of course
the bigger clue was the huge handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some
of the remaining boxes in the Attic he
wasn't exactly well versed in knitwear
but he could appreciate the craft behind
this soft blanket it clearly had a lot
of time and effort put into making it
painstakingly knitting each and every
individual thread looping it around a
pair of Steel needles and eventually f
after hours of wearing out shaking bony
fingers produce something that actually
looked quite nice even though the idea
of sitting and knitting a blanket might
have been one of the most boring uses of
time Milo could imagine he still had to
admit he was surprised that the Shaws
had left this particular piece of
bedding behind it seemed like it would
be pretty comfy to sleep under it might
help keep a person warm at night now
that the colder seasons were approaching
what's more was that the blanket was
clean almost like it had been freshly
washed there was no old person smell on
it no dirt or discoloration not a stain
and it hadn't even accumulated any dust
in its fibers in fact he noticed that
there was hardly any dust at all up in
the attic despite the house being empty
for so long he assumed the Realtors had
hired someone As a caretaker while they
found a buyer for the place and they had
kept the place clean after all what
other conclusion could they have
possibly drawn it's not as if something
had eaten all the dust that would be
concerned he'd have a sort through of
the Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell
some of it off at a local yard sale or
give it to a thrift store but that
blanket might come in handy when it
started snowing so Milo had half a mind
to keep it now part of what makes moving
home such a stressful life experience
isn't just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions buried deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the latter of his
two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either two best buds so confined
but pixel never went very far anyway
content to lay under a heat lamp almost
perfectly still for most of the day
donut on the other hand was much more of
a free spirit the tiny brown hamster
physically could not stay still and most
days seem to be filled with more energy
than Milo was as a result he let the
little guy roll about inside a little
plastic ball all day long until his
little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the Realtors had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water which would
quickly become an even bigger problem
when the weather started to get colder
then to top off the trifecta of
unforeseen issues and teething problems
with his new place Milo couldn't sleep
it was to be expected after all the
house was old worn out and had
definitely seen better days there were
bound to be a few noises the odd Creek
coming from upstairs when Milo and his
two pets were all downstairs the tapping
of branches against Windows blowing in
the wind outside but for some reason
every audible disturbance had emanated
from some hidden corner of the building
only seemed to get a thousand times
louder when the sun went down at night
time every squeaky floorboard or random
noise of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shahs showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at night Milo was seeing
the old couple in every bad dream he had
both their faces were locked in those
same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they try to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail in the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
furred hamster than the crates that
still littered the place grabbing the
leftover items that the shots had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the boiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor her when
Milo got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the floor
for one but more worryingly Donuts
plastic travel ball had been split open
laying in pieces on the ground with its
furry little occupant nowhere to be seen
over the next few hours Milo searched
every corner of the house calling out to
his hamster trying to lure it back with
more morsels of food but donut didn't
seem to be anywhere he wasn't even
underneath the knitted blanket still
there was no sign as worry set in Milo
Hurley checked pixel's cage to see if he
was gone too but the lizard was relaxing
as lethargic as ever completely unfazed
by what was going on it certainly seemed
that when it rained it really poured in
this new house just as he was searching
for his missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for the house is boiler burst
spending the afternoon into the evening
failing to track down one of his Missing
Pets and stopping the huge iron cast
boiler from flooding the basement wasn't
exactly what Milo had in mind for fun
activities to do when he got home going
to bed frustrated made it as hard to
sleep as all the nightly cacophony of
creaking floorboards and branches raking
against the windows he tapped out two of
the pills the doctor had prescribed him
knocking them back with a sharp motion
of his head and a swig of cold water
before laying back in bed as night had
fallen the temperature also had
plummeted too and not having a boiler to
heat his room meant that Milo couldn't
stop himself from shivering in the cold
his breath forming clouds in front of
his face he reached for the knitted
blanket and threw it over himself
curling up underneath it to try and
provide an extra layer of warmth to
protect himself from the nine cold the
pills did as they were meant to helping
Milo to quickly sleep into a much deeper
sleep than he had experienced in a while
although it didn't seem to help the
nightmares Mr and Mrs Shaw came back
again this time they had Milo's arms and
legs tied up with their matching
disapproving faces the elderly couple
threw something over their helpless
victim and tried to smother him to death
for a dream it felt so intense so real
Milo could feel a heavy weight on top of
his body as he slept in fact it felt
like it was all around him engulfing and
crushing the life out of him from all
sides but it was the feeling of
something wet against his arm the
sensation of liquid against his skin and
the numbness where his hands should be
were what finally pulled him out of the
dream and into the nightmare through the
dark and his cloudy vision Milo could
see a wide gaping moth filled with teeth
the feeling of being crushed was still
surrounding him and despite kicking his
legs and trying to free himself from
confinement it didn't stop squeezing him
tighter his Panic was already making it
harder to catch his breath but now he
could barely fill his lungs enough to
scream for help not that anyone was
around to hear him but it was the sight
of his arm that chilled Milo's blood it
wasn't there anymore part of it just
above the elbow was just gone his hand
fingers every internal bone and muscle
had been reduced to a bloody mess a
slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's under water and becomes sludge most
of his flesh was liquefied going further
up his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owners little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut before him know but
he'd been the victim of a creature that
was part of a rather unique species
while they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance scp-790 9 always seemed to be
ordinary items of knitted bedware at
least at first they retain heat like a
normal blanket would and are soft to the
touch and for the most part don't seem
directly harmful and usually they aren't
scp-799s are incapable of much movement
instead laying still a lot of time not
unlike a certain bearded dragon that
just lost its owner they also don't seem
to require much in the way of food
extracting with little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an scp-799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
well they possess this biological trait
themselves
scp-799 don't seem to regard
cold-blooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with Cold
Blood blood such as reptiles instead
scp-799 will metamorphose into a more
predatory form in order to consume any
warm-blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feed itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live now go and check out
scp-3032 and then it was an angry spider
for more warnings about everyday objects
that can seem harmless at first but will
quickly turn deadly when you least
expect it and after that if you're in
the market for a piece of anomalous
Furniture that's still soft and cozy
like the blanket but nowhere near as is
dangerous then
scp-3832 surprise pillow fight might be
just what you need